bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce vendredi
les pêcheurs toujours en colère
aujourd'hui le mouvement s'étend en
europe les négociations ont repris avec
le ministre michel barnier
le représentant des pêcheurs parle
d'avancés bruxelles donne son accord de
principe au système des deux français un
dramatique accident d'autocar sur
l'autoroute à 10 dans le loir-et-cher
sept personnes ont trouvé la mort la
nuit dernière
huit autres sont toujours dans un état
grave le car immatriculé en france
transportait des ressortissants
marocains
jérôme kerviel est il le seul
responsable du désastre financier qui a
touché la société générale at il
bénéficié de complicités ces dernières
heures un rapport interne de la banque
apporte vous le verrez de nouveaux
éléments de réponse
la gestion du patrimoine immobilier de
l'état en question ce soir également
autre rapport des parlementaires cette
fois attendue dans dijon et des montres
de sérieux dysfonctionnements
illustration de ces dérapages dans ce
journal
certains n'y croyaient plus mais
finalement la birmanie a décidé d'ouvrir
ses frontières aux ressorti cents
humanitaires étrangers
nos équipes sur place ont pu constater
de manière clandestine que certaines
zones étaient totalement démuni
aujourd'hui encore plus de deux millions
de personnes sont sinistrées et puis une
rencontre à la fin de ce journal il est
l'auteur français le plus populaire déjà
15 millions de livres vendus à travers
le monde
une adaptation qui à hollywood est un
succès et qui dérange le microcosme des
lettres il vient de sortir son dernier
roman nous parlerons de tout cela avec
lui marc levy notre invité ce soir
ils restent donc mobilisés aujourd'hui
en france les marins pêcheurs ont une
nouvelle fois multiplié les actions dans
le pas de calais plusieurs bateaux ont
effectué une opération escargot en
pleine mer qui a fortement perturbé la
circulation des navires marchands
en normandie des étals de grossistes de
poissons et l idée ça ni d'antiques
entre mareyeurs et pêcheurs à la criée
d'arcachon de nombreux ports reste
également toujours bloquée ce soir avant
de parler des négociations ont fait le
point avec amaury guibert et nous
équipes en région
c'est un nouveau signal de détresse
envoyé par les pêcheurs de
boulogne-sur-mer
trente cinq chalutiers quitte le port
avec un objectif inédit une opération
escargot dans le détroit du pas de
calais qui veut rester
a demandé de tenir la main et le trafic
sera fortement perturbé pour les
pêcheurs le message est passé
le porte monnaie
il n'y en avait pas besoin tout à
l'heure d'arcachon pour se procurer du
poisson mais le plaisir vient vous le
donnez parvenons à 7 15 centimes le kilo
on préfère leur égard pour le donner et
à la fin en même temps c'est pour le
gasoil ce nom peu plus cher plus d'une
tonne et demie de sardines et de daurade
distribué en quelques minutes avec ça
les pêcheurs sont sûrs de faire mouche
est une opération totalement qu'une
communication pour que tout le monde
nous entendre tout le monde vous voyez
que ce moment tout le monde rungis
réagir et faire réagir le même objectif
pour ces pêcheurs au péage de balaruc
sur l'a9 près de 7
je ne suis pas opposé à ce que vous le
fassiez d informer les usagers
le pétrole de maribor précipitamment
mais on peut pas
coupal a pas moins de dix minutes 10
minutes ça va être facile 4 3 3 tiens
c'est tout bon pour nous c'est tout bon
pour moi et après le poisson gratuit
voici le péage gratuit
nous ça nous touche directement le
gasoil mais bon après à la pop date il
voulait travailler c'est pareil le paye
plus de 10 francs le litre donc s'est
séparé donc na d'ouvrir les barrières
salomone quoi il faut qu'il faut pas
nous on fait des g et ça c'est aussi
pour eux parce que c'est ça devient
insupportable
baroud d'honneur ou pas à la rochelle
aussi les actions continuent la seule
ville où le dépôt de carburant est
encore bloqué donc on n'est pas beaucoup
on est un peu fatigués la colère de ces
pêcheurs là ne semblent pas près de se
consumer
voilà pour les actions sur le terrain
sur le plan politique les discussions
ont repris à rennes le ministre de la
pêche michel barnier a rencontré
aujourd'hui les présidents des comités
de pêche à leur sortie ils se sont dits
rassurés
bruxelles a également donné son accord
aux aides prévues par le gouvernement
français discussion et réactions avec
valérie le rouge et romuald de bonnans
l'explication de texte s'impose et
messieurs michel barnier n'ayant
visiblement pas convaincu tous les
marins avec son plan d'urgence
il vient sur le terrain pour tenter de
les persuader table ronde à rennes avec
les présidents de comité de pêche breton
des responsables convaincus par l'aide
sociale de 40 millions d'euros déjà
promise pour six mois et qui pourrait
être prolongé on a obtenu des aides
aujourd'hui qu'on n'a jamais eu encore à
la pêche on estime que le gasoil accords
jazzy bon là il faut le dire mais les
marins qui bloquent les ports eux
réclament non pas une compensation de la
hausse du gazole mais un prix fixe de 40
centimes le litre directement la pompe
réponse du ministre je ne peux pas
raconter d'histoires aux marins pêcheurs
veux pas être un ministre il le renverra
des chèques en bois un ministre est
quelqu'un de responsable et je fais
appel à des marins pêcheurs qui ont eux
aussi une responsabilité
un ministre n'est pas là pour raconter
des histoires le précédent système qui
était une aide directe à la pompe a été
condamné il a été supprimé nous allons
devoir rembourser un veto de bruxelles
c'est justement ce que craignent les
pêcheurs qui ne croient pas à ce nouveau
plan
lors d'un déplacement en lituanie le
premier ministre s'est voulu rassurant
nous avons l'accord des autorités
européennes des autorités européennes
sur les dispositions qui ont été
proposées pour aider les pêcheurs
français à surmonter la crise preuve que
le dossier devient très politique les
marins de la rochelle ont reçu la visite
de ségolène royal la présidente de la
région poitou charentes leur a promis
une aide de 500 mille euros en attendant
les premiers chaque de l'état et ce
mouvement des pêcheurs contre les prix
du gazole pourrait prendre une dimension
européenne à zeebrugge en belgique
les marins ont d'ailleurs manifesté
aujourd'hui leur confrère italien
portugais et espagnols ont pris date
également autre profession touchée par
cette crise des carburants les
chauffeurs routiers
plusieurs syndicats ont justement menacé
d'agir dans les prochains jours en
revanche aujourd'hui une manifestation
d'agriculteurs a eu lieu à jeun ils
réclament quant à eux 1
carburant professionnel totalement
détaxés alors quel est le tarif du baril
de pétrole aujourd'hui eh bien il est de
130 dollars 50 à new york en légère
baisse par rapport à hier
les pays de l'opep reconnaissent que le
marché est devenu complètement fou sur
un an le prix du baril a donc plus que
doublé alors sommes-nous face à un
troisième choc pétrolier
c'est la question économique du jour
éléments de réponse avec sophie brune et
philippe chasselas octobre 73 en pleine
guerre du kippour entre israël et les
pays arabes les pays producteurs de
l'opep décide de fermer les vannes les
livraisons de pétrole diminue le prix du
baril passant quelques semaines de 3 à
18 dollars c'est le premier choc
pétrolier en france les consommateurs se
plaignent déjà de l'envolée des prix et
les conséquences comme tout le monde
25 ans plus tard le baril frôle les 135
dollars sur les marchés les prix sont
tirés par la forte demande des pays
émergents
s'agit-il alors du troisième choc
pétrolier
on est vraiment dans la situation que
des bises et 110 puisque la hausse du
prix a vraiment le la même cause c'est
l'accélération de la demande et
l'insuffisance de l'offre
quelles conséquences sur l'économie pour
l'instant elles sont limitées car depuis
le premier choc pétrolier la france a
appris à consommer moins de pétrole 130
millions de tonnes en 73 contre cent
l'an dernier
la france a en effet fait le choix du
nucléaire pour produire son électricité
quelles conséquences pour les pays
émergents dans plusieurs pays du
moyen-orient en inde ou encore en chine
les consommateurs ne subissent pas
vraiment la hausse des cours
c'est l'état qui met la main à la poche
ces pays mettent l'accent sur un pétrole
à bas prix pour encourager la croissance
économique et sont prêts à payer des
subventions massives pour continuer à
préserver leurs consommateurs des
conséquences de la hausse des prix du
pétrole
la flambée actuelle du baril n'a pas
encore de conséquences aussi graves que
lors des précédents chocs pétroliers
mais si les cours continuent leur
progression toutes les économies
finiront par être touchée et âme ou
encore d'économie avec le ch et de la
consommation des ménages qui est en
légère baisse pour le mois d'avril une
baisse de 0 8%
seule la consommation des biens
d'équipement et de logements et en os
sur cette période dans l'actualité de ce
vendredi également ce dramatique
accident la nuit dernière d'un autocar
près de blois sur l'a10 il a fait sept
morts et huit blessés graves
un choc d'une extrême violence le bus
transportait une trentaine de passagers
originaires du maroc le roi mohammed vi
a très vite réagi aujourd'hui souhaitant
prendre en charge le rapatriement des
victimes
reportage bernard lebrun et sylvain doba
des accidents sur l'autoroute a10 les
140 gendarmes et pompiers du
loir-et-cher mobilisés ce matin en ont
vu des centaines mais un comme cela
jamais celui d'un autocar de plusieurs
tonnes qui gravit le pilier d'un pont
d'autoroute pour s'y encastrer à 110 km
heure un choc frontal invraisemblable
dira même le secrétaire d'état aux
transports
en découvrant les lieux et le véhicule
un autocar vieux de 11 ans sans ceinture
de sécurité
il y avait des personnes éjectées ceci
étant avec ou sans ceinture
malheureusement les personnes qui
étaient situés à l'avant du car quand
vous observez la manière d'occuper pas
casque dans le pont même s'il avait
porté une ceinture
malheureusement ce n'aurait pas changé
grand chose l'autocar et français ont
encore immatriculés dans l'eure mais il
appartient depuis 2006 à cette société
de transport en commun de la région
parisienne pour 60 euros
un petit prix elle offre le trajet paris
casablanca partie du sud du maroc le bus
roulait depuis deux jours le dernier
relais entre les deux chauffeurs avait
eu lieu deux heures avant l'accident
trente passagers eux dormaient à bord
tous marocains alors dès cet après-midi
dans les hôpitaux de blois tours et
orléans
l'ambassadeur du maroc à paris est venu
visiter les blessés sauf les quatre
victimes dont le pronostic vital est
engagé
d autres ils reviennent de loin
j'ai vu des gens morts chrome sans pales
angers que s'est il passé
deux enquêtes ont été ouvertes l'une
judiciaire l'autre technique sur la
route une trace d'explosion de pneus a
été retrouvée qui dévie nettement la
trajectoire du bus dans la barrière de
sécurité mais les enquêteurs n'excluent
pas une autre hypothèse que le chauffeur
se soit endormie purement et simplement
autre accident celui qui a coûté la vie
hier à une mère et à ses deux enfants à
marsa et fauchée par une moto accidentée
on a aujourd'hui que le motard
conduisait sous le coup d'une annulation
de permis
la conductrice de la voiture qui l'a
percuté quand elle n'avait plus de
points sur le sien mais elle l'ignorait
ce soir le secrétaire d'état aux
transports dominique bussereau a annoncé
sur rtl qu'une loi serait présenté
prochainement pour permettre la
confiscation immédiate du véhicule d'un
conducteur contrôlé sans permis de
conduire et revoilà la sphère kerviel la
société générale a rendu ce soir son
rapport interne sur cette affaire un
rapport qui éclaire vous allez le voir
certaines zones d'ombré la première
d'entre elles le jeune trader at il
bénéficié de complicités dans ce
désastre financier bien la réponse
serait oui julien beaumont fabien shadow
jérôme kerviel n'est peut-être pas le
seul en cause dans la sphère société
générale une affaire qui a coûté 4,9
milliards d'euros à la banque
c'est en tout cas les conclusions d'un
rapport réalisé par l'inspection
générale de la société générale
71 pages dans lesquelles on découvre que
je cite la hiérarchie du trader s'est
avéré défaillant dans la supervision de
ses activités
le supérieur immédiat manqué
d'expérience première nouveauté du
dossier car jusqu'à présent la direction
avait toujours soutenu que jérôme
kerviel avait réussi à tromper son monde
a dupé sa hiérarchie
on apprend ainsi que des supérieurs
qualifié aurait sans doute pu le stopper
à temps autre affirmation le trader
aurait bien eu un complice
son insiste en interne qui aurait saisi
les nombreuses opérations de nature
frauduleuses
là aussi cette citation réfute la thèse
d'un jérôme kerviel
agissant seule opération mains propres
pour la société générale
mais attention cette enquête interne n'a
pas de valeur juridique
le pôle financier lui poursuit son
enquête de son côté son avocat juste
considérer ce soir que ce rapport allait
dans le sens de la défense du trader
affaire à suivre l'état de son côté ne
serait toujours pas un bon gestionnaire
de son patrimoine immobilier
ce n'est pas nouveau mais cela continue
un rapport sur la question doit être
rendu dans quelques jours par des
parlementaires et les premières
informations issues de leur travail tend
à démontrer qu'en la matière on marche
parfois sur la tête et la nuque
daniel levy palais où hôtel particulier
depuis cinq ans l'état vend ses
immeubles inoccupés pour réduire sa
dette
pas toujours avec un grand sens des
affaires exemple en 2003 il se sépare de
l'imprimerie nationale vendu 85 millions
d'euros
quatre ans plus tard le ministère des
affaires étrangères la rachète quatre
fois plus cher au passage merci negi de
taxer la plus value réalisée par le
vendeur
épinglé également brice hortefeux le
ministre de l'immigration
installé au 101 rue de grenelle il veut
louer l'immeuble voisin pour installer
son administration sur le problème de
l'immeuble d'à côté c'est que vous êtes
en plein 7e arrondissement de paris rue
de grenelle et que compte tenu des
différentes opérations le coût du mètre
carré ressort à 8 cents
800 850 euros par mètre carré or nous
nous considérons qu'à 300 350 euros le
mètre carré
on pouvait trouver sans difficulté et
donc vingt propositions va propositions
ont été faites au ministère de
l'immigration
il les a refusées les vins dans le
collimateur encore le ministère de la
justice qui paient chaque année plus de
20 millions d'euros de loyers une partie
est englouti pour héberger ses
fonctionnaires dans le sillage
historique et prestigieux de canal+
accusé également le ministère de la
culture qui reloge ses principales
directions en plein coeur de paris a
précisé qu'ils étaient paris
ben ketai paris avec des personnels qui
sont vraiment qu'ils travaillent
vraiment basque avec l'administration
centrale qui ont des multiples réunions
etc
c'est pas très commode si vous voulez
chaque ministère a toujours une bonne
raison d'expliquer pourquoi il ne se
soumettra pas une règle commune
et je le dis en ciblant personnes à
titre personnel mais si l'état des
ministres jusqu'au haut fonctionnaire ne
comprend pas que maintenant on n'a plus
les moyens de ce type d'opération vient
dans ces cas-là nous n'arriverons jamais
ce qui a été fait dans le monde entier à
rétablir nos comptes publics
quelques bons points cependant au
ministère de l'éducation qui réduit ses
locaux au même rythme que le nombre de
ses fonctionnaires à la défense
également et son projet de regroupement
de ses services dans un pentagone à la
française
la politique avec le parti socialiste
qui compte ses candidats au poste de
premier secrétaire pour le congrès de
novembre prochain à défaut pour le
moment de faire acte de candidature
bertrand delanoë sera un livre intitulé
de l'audace il réunira demain ses amis
la mutualité une chose est sûre en tout
cas chacun des candidats déclarés ou non
a le même leitmotiv faire oublier la
guerre des chefs et mettre en avant le
débat d'idées une ligne de conduite on
le sait fragile
j'habite imbert ann guy et p pour lui il
n'ya pas de duel pas de combat des chefs
pas d'enjeux de pouvoir au ps il se
demande même ce matin en souriant
pourquoi les photographes sont là
avant devant sa mairie bertrand delanoë
vote symboliquement pour le droit de
vote aux étrangers sont livré sa formule
choc libéral et socialiste ont fait
l'actualité il réunit ses troupes demain
mais ce sera tout les candidatures sont
livrés doit tout est respecté ya pas de
séguéla il ya beaucoup de candidatures
au poste de premier secrétaire
mon transfert à la bouche de candidature
eh bien écoutez moi je n'ai pas pris de
décision je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que je ne suis pas impatient et je
ne suis pas en appétit de pouvoir fera
plus impatientes mis en appétit de
pouvoir lui répondrai sans doute
ségolène royal mais elle est
officiellement en course pour le parti y
est en campagne aujourd'hui avec les
marins pêcheurs mardi avec les métallos
cgt en grève en lorraine ségolène royal
agacé que certains l'apprennent d'eau
beaucoup de deivid enel vont émerger
quelques est comprise par 47% des
français et donc on ne part pas de rien
et je ne veux pas qu'il n'y de mépris et
d'écrasement dans un scénario classique
le prochain congrès se résumera cela un
duel delanoë royal mais rien on le sait
n'est simple au psg voilà le retour de
dominique strauss kahn
pas pour le congrès mais peut-être pour
2012 ses amis se sont réunis dimanche
dernier à paris candidate martine aubry
revient néanmoins au premier plan elle
serait sollicitée par les
reconstructeurs une nouvelle alliance
dans le ps a le secret bref ça se
complique encore ajouté pierre moscovici
julien dray ou manuel valls intéressés
par la tête du parti ou pourquoi pas la
présidentielle
n'en jetez plus trop de candidatures
cette semaine quelques grands élus
contenté de dire ce temps françois
hollande doit observer la période avec
un peu d'amusement
il n'est pas si facile à remplacer
nicolas sarkozy et en angola aujourd'hui
le président la république entendait
tourner la page des années de brouille
causée notamment par l' affaire de
l'angolagate
il était accompagné du patron du groupe
total christophe de margerie qui a
répété qu'il souhaitait développer
encore ses activités avec le pays
enfin la birmanie a enfin accepté de
laisser entrer les humanitaires
étrangers sur son territoire pour venir
en aide aux sinistrés
l'annoncé a été faite par le secrétaire
général des nations unies ban ki moon
sur le terrain cette aide est plus que
réclamez malgré l'optimisme affiché par
les autorités dans certaines zones
touchées aucune aide n'est pas revenu
depuis plusieurs semaines c'est le cas
de la région de bogal est situé à cette
heure de route de rangoon notre équipe a
pu se rendre sur place de manière
clandestine
c'est le grand format de ce soir il est
signé arnaud mig et daniel et mathias
second attention certaines images
peuvent heurter certains téléspectateurs
regardent et 5 heures du matin district
de bô galets
le trajet pour arriver jusqu'ici et
épuisant sept heures de route
puis le bateau nous embarquons avec ces
moines dont vous ne verrez pas les
visages
tout le monde a peur dans cette
dictature tropicale même ceux qui ne
cherchent aujourd'hui qu'à et des rares
sont les visiteurs qui se sont aventurés
jusqu'ici sur la rivière tenez kouaoua
et ces sinistrés ont besoin de tout
alors aujourd'hui on leur donne des
vêtements quand j'ai entendu parler
un cyclone en birmanie je me suis de
suite ce que nous diront nos ventes à
l'étranger
on devait tout faire pour aider les non
j'ai envoyé des tas de messages pour
récolter des dons à ce que je voulais
apporter moi-même et maintenant c'est ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de faire
premier arrêt au village de saint malo
ici on n'a pas vu un bateau arrivé
depuis le cyclone alors quand il ya
distribution
forcément c'est un peu la bousculade
naviguer dans ce delta de l'irrawaddy
cd'aujourd'hui voyager au coeur des
ténèbres les corps flottent à la surface
ils les rescapés semblaient à la dérive
maisons détruites villages entiers rasés
la petite île de sart mal ou du samedi
vie est née il ya 33 ans ressemble à un
champ de bataille ici un quart des
habitants ont été emportés par le vent
il ne lui reste que ces titres de
propriété bien dérisoire quand on a tout
perdu maison femmes et enfants quand la
tempête a commencé
les enfants pleuraient ma femme s'est
accrochée à moi j'ai regardé à
l'extérieur le sial on était tous roux
et puis le vent et les eaux nous ont
tous séparés
j'ai tout perdu je pense que je ne
pourrai rien reconstruire l'heure n'est
pas à la reconstruction mais à l'aide
d'urgence
trois semaines après la catastrophe ils
attendent toujours nourriture aux
médicaments solitude d'un peuple
abandonné qui appelle ses coûts les
birmans ont peur de dire du mal de ceux
qui sont au pouvoir
même s'ils connaissent très bien la
réalité ils n'ont rien fait pour nous
aider
aujourd'hui on a besoin de l'aide
humanitaire internationale des nations
unies des états unis
il faut nous aider à sauver ce pays
sauver la birmanie et ses deux millions
de sinistrés
en chine une nouvelle conséquence du
tremblement de terre reconnu
officiellement 50 sources radioactives
ont été détectés selon les autorités
chinoises dans la zone touchée par le
séisme
une information à suivre quand on sait
que plusieurs bâtiments de recherches
secrètes ainsi que des usines chimiques
sont situés dans la région
renaud bernard voici l'une des fuites
ici ce sont des produits chimiques qui
menace d'exploser
les pompiers du sichuan l'ont découverte
par hasard sur la route qui mène à
l'épicentre du séisme
il faut vite diluer ses produits
chimiques
attention soyez très prudents onze jours
pour que les autorités chinoises là vous
dans la région du tremblement de terre
les usines chimiques mais surtout les
sites radioactifs ont été endommagés par
le séisme
hier midi six de nos équipes spéciales
ont repéré 50 sources radioactives
dangereuses
aucune des neuf centrales nucléaires du
pays n'aurait été touché
elles sont très éloignés du sichuan mais
dans la province dévastée
il y a le principal laboratoire chinois
de recherche sur les armes nucléaires
amy yang yang il y a aussi plusieurs
sites atomiques secret selon pékin 3
sont complètement détruits douze autres
bâtiments seraient trop instable pour
être sécurisé plus inquiétant les
autorités disent avoir détecté 15 autres
sources radioactives mais elles ne les
ont pas localisé en revient en france
avec des nouvelles d'un trésor vieux de
17 mille ans la grotte de lascaux
chef-d'oeuvre de la préhistoire
serait-elle en péril
elle est envahie par un champignon qui
pourrait à terme faire disparaître les
dessins ce défenseur poussa un cri
d'alarmé florence mavic mathieu dreujou
seuls quelques rares privilégiés sont
autorisés à contempler ce fabuleux
bestiaire gravé sur l'offre de la pierre
découverte en 1940 la grotte de lascaux
en dordogne ne supporte que
difficilement la présence de l'homme
fermée au public en 1963 elle subit les
assauts répétés de moisissures d'algues
de dioxyde de carbone ou de dépôt de
calcite chaque remèdes apportés par les
restaurateurs semblent entraîner de
nouveaux problèmes
aujourd'hui ce sont ces taches noires
qui attaquent les parois des champignons
surgit vraisemblablement à la suite de
travaux de conservation les
restaurateurs pris au dépourvu par cette
prolifération fongiques sont restés des
heures entières avec des milliers
d'heures au fur et à mesure sur huit ans
et il était dans la grotte et ils
avaient leurs éclairages et tout ça
c'est ça fait chauffer la grotte sur ces
bois de cerf on voit que le champignon
recouvre inexorablement les peintures au
ministère de la culture on se veut
rassurant se gardant de faire porter la
responsabilité sur les différents
intervenants ces mesures sont
aujourd'hui on résume pour l'essentiel
nous l'assurent ils ont bien évidemment
au terme d'un traitement chimique qui
tentent de ralentir l'expansion du
champignon la grotte est actuellement en
repos à la recherche d'un équilibre
perdu
il aime raconter des anecdotes des
souvenirs les siens ou ceux des autres
il en fait les romans et cela plaît au
public
marc levy est l'auteur français le plus
lu aujourd'hui des millions
d'exemplaires pour une littérature
populaire qui dérange parfois le petit
monde des lettres
l'artisan marc lévy comme il aime se
définir est avec nous mais avant de le
retrouver tentant de comprendre pourquoi
un tel succès avec nicolas le marinier
et annie tri boire toutes ces choses
qu'on ne s'est pas dites sorti la
semaine dernière le dernier roman de
marc levy est déjà un succès une
réussite que l'auteur doit à un public
fidèle majoritairement féminin même si
certaines lectrices sont fâchés avec les
titres de ses romans c'est toujours des
titres courts avec des points
d'interrogation
je retrouve le titre assis avec eux de
la petite fille qui a disparu et qu'on
va trouver en fait fait ouais c'est bien
avec marc levy pas de demi-mesure on est
complètement fan ou alors on passe son
chemin
j'ai dû c'est regarder derrière de ses
bouquins ça m'a inspiré plus que ça
depuis dix ans le parcours de marc levy
c'est un peu des chiffres et des lettres
15 millions d'ouvragés vendus dans le
monde lui roman traduit en 39 langues
et si c'était vrai son premier succès a
été porté à l'écran par hollywood
en attendant un autre film tiré d'un
autre livre
cet été régulièrement descendu par la
critique le romancier prend les
reproches avec philosophie hercules et
depuis dix ans il raconte des histoires
dans l'air du temps c'est justement ces
histoires contemporaines être jeu et si
tu les as piennes quoi c'est vraiment
tout se termine bien voilà donc ça fait
partie c'est sûrement un peu comme un
bonbon quoi quelque chose qui vous fait
plaisir
ils s'effacent hilaliens recettes
d'écriture ou vrai talent quoiqu'en
pensent chacun marc levy ne laisse
personne indifférent voilà son nouveau
roman s'intitule toutes ces choses qu'on
ne s'est pas dit chez robert laffont
bonsoir marc levy merci d'être avec nous
alors vous êtes déjà en tête des ventes
de livres en france avec ce nouveau
roman
vous avez quoi un fluide magique des
mots qui envoûte les lecteurs bref c'est
quoi votre secret ecoutez jean sérien
fera que j'ai beaucoup de chance surtout
et et je travaille je travaille beaucoup
mais mais pour le reste je m'intéresse
pas suffisamment à moi même pour essayer
d'aller rechercher le pourquoi du
comment
alors je travaille beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup et alors qu'est ce qu'on
ressent lorsqu'on s'installe quelque
part et que l'on voit des hommes des
femmes des inconnus pour vous qui sont
plongés dans votre lit et cela ça vous
arrive la plage ou à la terrasse d'un
café qu'est ce qu'on ressent moi ça me
donne un trac terrible en fait
ça m'arrive ça n'arrive pas si souvent
que ça mais les quelques fois où ça
m'est arrivé je suis un vrai traque de
voir qu'elle est une femme en train de
lire 1 1 mais livre et j'ai donc je vais
plus préféré quitter l'endroit
en général ils vont jusqu'au bout en
tout cas vous vous présentez comme un
conteur et non pas comme un écrivain
pourquoi est ce que la critique en tout
cas une partie d'entre elles je le
disais parfois dur avec vous est ce
qu'elle a fini par vous toucher cette
critique non d'avoir 7 et 13 euros début
ça allait un peu moins maintenant et
puis la critique critique moi j'écris
vous savez la plus belle des critiques
quand on est un artisan ccsl des gens
qui vous lisent
voilà le livre est sorti et quelques
jours j'ai déjà reçu énormément de mails
de courriers de lecteurs qui sont
heureux du livre et c'est la plus belle
des critiques celles des gens pour
lesquels on écrit alors une question se
nomme sur la concurrence un nouvel
auteur vous talonne dans les ventes
aujourd'hui s'appelle guillaume musso je
crois on y retrouve quelques similitudes
est ce que vous avez lu ses livres et
que vous inspire-t-il finalement écouté
d'abord c'est pas une course de formule
1 et non moi je dépends je n'ai pas lu
ses livres
je reçois beaucoup de mails de lecteurs
qui me parle de ses livres on ne peut
pas reprocher à quai au taz on ne peut
pas reprocher un auteur de faire entrer
des gens dans les librairies et de faire
lire il ya des similitudes
oui c'est vrai en forme en a parlé en
tout cas j'ai noté où il ya des
similitudes dans les titres il ya des
similitudes dans les sagas dans les
situations dans les régions non non pas
dû écouter c'est très flatteur en même
temps tout d'abord je suis très heureux
de son succès et ils sont ils sont su
qu'il ne doit certainement pas
uniquement son succès qu'à ses
similitudes loin de là et et puis en
même temps si j'ai ouvert une voie que
c'est très flatteur pour moi je
voilà je suis sûr qu'un jour il arrivera
à faire des romans sans consigne à ses
similitudes mais mes jeux mais en tout
cas il fait rentrer des milliers de gens
dans les librairies et c'est formidable
bah comme vous alors merci en tout cas
marc levy toutes ces choses nous qu'on
ne s'est pas dit c'est votre dernier
roman aux éditions robert laffont
merci beaucoup nous sommes fin mai et
c'est la période de révision des examens
qui va commencer comme toujours elle
correspond avec roland garros france
télévisions sera bien sûr au rendez vous
dès dimanche le tirage au sort a eu lieu
ce matin
comme c'est la tradition en présence du
tenant du titre rafael nadal quelques
matches les français arnaud clément et
gaël monfils se retrouveront face à face
dès le premier tour
amélie mauresmo rencontrera la russe
olga sache look et richard gasquet sera
quant à lui opposé à un autre français
florent serra
richard gasquet qui sort d'une année
difficile alors où en est le numéro un
du tennis tricolore et le numéro 9
mondial rencontre avec nathanaël de
rincquesen et philippe muge rhin depuis
début de la semaine ils ne font pas ces
heures passées sur la terre battue de
roland garros richard gasquet enchaîne
les séances d'entraînement il y a
urgence
cette saison le meilleur joueur français
balbutient son tennis alors cette
semaine il a changé d'entraîneur
méthodes de travail
deuxième point de rentrer dans le
terrain sont à inverser le cours de
change à la recherche de sa confiance
perdue les deux hommes ont encore
quelques jours pour tenter de sauver ce
qui peut l'être encore aux
internationaux de france
ça ressemble un coup de poker est ce que
c'est un choix toujours hasardeuse mais
c'est un choix qui qui peut payer il a
retrouvé le plaisir de jouer on l'a vu
s'entraîner depuis une semaine à roland
garros avec beaucoup plus d'assiduité
que les semaines précédentes
les ennuis de richard gasquet remonte au
mois dernier et à la rencontre de coupe
davis face aux etats-unis ce week-end là
le numéro un français peut motiver peut
concerner peu présent et violemment
critiqué par les médias
coïncidence depuis il ne gagne plus le
moral semble atteint
la confiance s'est envolée
je suis humain donc ça attire maintenant
même d'avoir mal à déserter comme ça des
gens qui avaient des choses un peu un
peu dur et pas toujours très justifiées
même pas du tout justifiée donc c'est
sûr que ça fait toujours mal pour ce
pour se concentrer se préparer sur le
tas n'est pas toujours facile a promis
hier richard gasquet a passé l'après
midi dans un club familial de la
banlieue parisienne
rien de tel qu'un petit match amical
pour retrouver l'envi et se reconstruira
moral de champion avant roland garros
plaisir combativité puis croquer croquer
ce rôle au maximum quand baugé
voilà voilà les deux choses auxquelles
sur lesquels j'ai insisté lourdement les
chats en attendant le début du tournoi
le numéro un français a battu le tchèque
stepanek en deux manches
un succès symbolique mais efficace le
clan gasquet a retrouvé le sourire et
c'est un week-end exceptionnel de sport
sur france 2 avec également la finale de
la coupe de rugby
le choc opposera demain à 18 heures à
cardiff le stade toulousain aux
irlandais du munster
a toulouse la ville se prépare à vibrer
pour l'événement manuel tissier
la fièvre monte à toulouse une fièvre
acheteuse qui parcourt la boutique du
club
demain le stade toulousain tentera
d'accrocher à ces tuniques une quatrième
étoile de champion d'europe record
continental dans les tribunes du stade
de cardiff ils seront cinq mille à
porter leurs couleurs et bien plus
devant l'écran géant du centre ville il
ya trois étoiles
ken 4,84 qu'est-ce qu'on fait leurs
valises à toulouse on change de
casquette plus facilement que
d'entraîneur depuis 16 ans guy novès est
de toutes les campagnes jette
actuellement à 42 minutes de la pop up
et chatoyant comme l otan en janvier 96
c'est toulousains emmenés par thomas
castaignède ouvrait le palmarès de la
coupe d'europe dans l'ancien stade de
cardiff en 12 ans toulouse a discuté
trois autres finales pour deux victoires
demain il affronte un autre géant
d'europe les irlandais du leinster
une équipe en forme et qui joue aussi en
rouge si multiples quitte à les mettre
une menace à gloucester qui veut que le
leader du championnat mais qui est allé
battre elle et ses racines chez eux
des quarts de finale et demi-finale je
passe pas couché en favori dans ce final
cinquante mille supporters irlandais
sont attendus au millennium de cardiff
dix fois plus que les toulousains mais
les français ont gagné le droit par
tirage au sort de garder leurs couleurs
comme l'équipe de france vainqueur des
all blacks dans le même stade
il y as vu moi direction cannes
maintenant avec l'un de ces événements
caritatifs qui se déroulant en marge du
festival sharon stone a une nouvelle
fois mobilisé de nombreuses stars au
bénéfice de la fondation américaine de
lutte contre le sida un dîner et une
vente aux enchères qui ont rapporté en
quelques heures vous allez le voir 10
millions de dollars reportage estelle
colin olivier robert sharon stone assez
de la célébrité
un métier elle gère son image avec une
précision toute militaire
chaque apparition et calibrés chaque
intervention minutes et autant dire que
pour les gendarmes de cannes ce corps à
corps futin lundi pour évoquer cette
soirée danseurs pour la lutte contre le
sida et les différentes associations
pour lesquelles elle milite sharon stone
va y mettre toute son énergie mais avec
lucidité
la soirée sera fini on aura toujours
besoin de gagner de l'argent pour faire
parvenir les médicaments malade pour
assainir l'eau puisse tourner leurs
médicaments
ensuite il faudra travailler à la paix
rhdp
il y aura toujours quelque chose à faire
gyrophares routes barrées cris de
badauds la maîtresse de cérémonie et là
mais le chemin est long pour cette vente
aux enchères la plus folle de la planète
10 millions de dollars en un soir deux
premiers millions de la table 100 mille
euros 800 invités dans le conte du
commissaire priseur une nouvelle recrue
madonna pour faire monter les enchères
le jus ou séductrice de choc avec le
rappeur puff daddy alors tu veux pas les
crash étaient 320 milles
jeudi 300 femmes jeudi 300 ch et 320
milles s'ils l'ont fait cuit sortie de
star par les cuisines même le samu
social aura lieu aussi sa petite photo
du glamour n'ai pas vu des très bonnes
intentions avant de refermer ce journal
je vous en rappelle l'une des
principales informations c'est la
mobilisation encore et toujours des
marins pêcheurs en france plusieurs
actions aujourd'hui de nombreux ports
bloqués cependant les négociations entre
le ministre michel barnier et les
représentants de la profession ont
laissé entrevoir des avancées la
commission européenne a donné son aval à
l'aide proposée par le gouvernement
français
voilà pour l'actualité de ce vendredi
merci d'être fidèle à l'info sur france
2 demain je vous retrouve dès 13h pour
le journal et le magazine à 13h15 dans
un instant la météo isabelle martinez
suivi du point route malawi maurice
20h55 notre série sur le fil passé une
très belle soirée et j'espère à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur fond
votre soirée sur france 2